a pesar de los trabajos y de las
carreras de las autoridades ucranianas
parte del país continúa sin electricidad
esta noche en la capital kiev según las
autoridades el 60% de las viviendas
todavía no tienen luz eléctrica Aunque
sí se ha restablecido el servicio de
agua y en Odessa donde nos encontramos
la tercera ciudad del país la situación
es más o menos similar si pueden
escuchar un poco se odian las plantas y
es bastante interesante porque solamente
algunos sectores donde hay edificaciones
gubernamentales tienen ya restablecida
la electricidad esta calle que está al
frente mío la tiene pero si nos movemos
metros más Allí están sin electricidad y
esto ha llevado a que se operen decenas
de lugares donde las personas pueden ir
a cargar sus celulares especialmente en
estos restaurantes o locales que tienen
plantas eléctri si las autoridades se
han pedido a esos sectores que sí tienen
electricidad que por favor reduzcan el
consumo lo mínimo posible porque la
infraestructura no está soportando
mayores consumos durante estas horas
mientras que las autoridades hacen todo
lo posible por restablecer otra vez el
servicio en todo el país después de ese
ataque masivo de las fuerzas rusas en el
día de ayer en el que 70 misiles fueron
lanzados contra Ucrania 51 de ellos
fueron interceptados pero el resto
atacaron infraestructura energética
bastante importante que tiene el país en
estas circunstancias desde el día de
ayer por las autoridades han dicho que
esperan que mañana de la situación
vuelva a normalizarse sin embargo vemos
mucha gente en la calle en este momento
aquí en Odessa tratando de huir del frío
de sus casas y también de buscando un
poco de lugares donde conectar sus
celulares